yeah god no
please shut mouth no not another one
is it another challenge that you want
Malcolm then I am ready but wait I gotta
put on my hater blockers I actually
can't see anything you can make me laugh
nothing makes me laugh let's pretend you
are visiting PewDiePie on 8th ok cubed
that's like a dating site I know that I
do not make that profile myself summary
first and foremost I am a sir always
seem to find myself in the in the
friendzone I am a really nice guy that
would rather spend a night cuddling than
having sex I am a I am a I am I have a
proud a theist and attend many free
thinking rallies wake up sheeple the
first thing people usually notice about
me my fedora I've never seen without it
kiss-kiss apart of me I spent a lot of
time thinking about how people can be so
blind and follow organized religion and
if I'll ever get out of the on a typical
Friday night I am relaxing at home with
their glass of brandy and my thoughts
the most private thing I'm willing to
admit I'm still a virgin and I watch
anime that's not true whatever alright
whatever you think you think you're
funny
they didn't even laugh so far I'm fine
oh you got a video next that's cute
I'll play it
I'm fine that was not a laugh so far I'm
beating you at your own game
[ __ ] Malcolm I bet you are a virgin and
watch enemy you probably ate so it
actually makes sense but whatever next
one I have to be someone on the internet
because I'm know I'll have you know I am
very popular in real life as well I have
many friends shut up
Oh another video that's cute here we go
didn't laugh all right next one hey
pittypat kill urself pls PDP I found
dead this is offensive to dead people
I'm gonna post this on tumblr I saw this
post on tumblr and I just want to say
this is extremely offensive not only to
me but to the people of the universe of
his triggered skirt and ball in there ok
here we go
samurai cops he speaks fluent Japanese
they call him samurai he speaks fluent
Japanese are you food
Fujiyama what does katana mean it means
Japanese sword
hilarious
moving on oh yeah baby tell me what you
want to talk to me like you're a [ __ ]
idiot
PewDiePie is the best YouTube channel
that's perfect
hey I mean whatever gets her off am i
right
pound it
Oh another video fine
the videos are the hardest man I can't
[ __ ] do the videos let's watch it
PewDiePie video starter pack ok cool
shirt hey I got one of those cool
sunglasses I got them
autism I got it
grape juice my favorite
how to watch a pity pie video method one
out of three commit suicide
oh yeah so you're telling me that 43
million people killed themselves that
doesn't even make any sense man this is
too easy
come on Turkish man and people call my
videos [ __ ] we did act oh and don't
[ __ ] and don't forget that pity pie
sucks only in it for the money we've
done good infiltrating his system now we
move on to face - wait why maced you now
my sleeper agents it's time to be
activated initiate phase two convert
septic for life the war has only just
begun
because you're fat too
that was another great video leave a
like if you enjoyed subscribe to become
a bro today watch the other part of
tryna to live challenge let me know if
you did it or not do you complete the
challenge be honest
and as always thank you both so much for
watching my videos I really appreciate
it stay awesome bros schizophrenic
Robert DeNiro absolute Maul 100% percent
dankest this is [ __ ] hardest [ __ ] G I